[Music]
hey before we get into this highlight
clip we just want to let you know we're
doing a live show from the ship
july 29 moment house dot com slash tiny
meat gang
tell them what we're doing we're doing
it's gonna be so much fun we got dj's
head from spock
we got a live that's cringe we're doing
a new cody noel do we're premiering it
no one's ever seen it we learned how to
sword fight it's [ __ ] insane yep and
we got some sketches that we made too
and two hours or more of us just riffing
and yeah
might have some special guests drop by
all around good time
so yeah come join us it's going to be
it's going to be awesome and
you know just so you all know once the
show happens it'll be available for
24 hours after the show happens so in
case you bought a ticket but you miss it
you can still watch it for the day after
but after that
it's finito is gone so uh make sure you
tune in
july 29th it's gonna be a good time
momenthouse.com slash tiny meat gang
tickets i'm talking about my fan though
that i rented yeah
so i wanted to get into the van life
lifestyle yeah see what it's all about
my friend my friend like five years ago
bought a mercedes sprinter
yes and spent like six months didn't
know what the [ __ ] he was doing just
spent six months
like turning it into a camper van
himself but learning it all along the
way so i was like we went surfing with
him on time he had this camper van he
had a shower it was [ __ ]
unreal and uh i was always like jealous
of that
and then um i've been watching like van
life videos just on youtube i was like
when does this rabbit hole they're
awesome
they're [ __ ] awesome but it's also
there's like a weird
you know the ones that weird me out is
when they're raising a baby in it yes
yes dude we were joking about that along
the way because i was filming a little
bit of it
with the intention of making a video i
didn't film enough but we were
like just joking about yeah we just we
sold our place
and we're living on the road now it's
like
especially if you're like a family it's
like why don't you try and do it
the right way yeah there is no right way
now there's a right way man yeah
baby's like getting scrambled
on the way to utah
in a bread basket literally
you don't have to raise it like it's 400
bc you know raised out in nature with
the mountain it's a it's a baby
yeah it wants milk and to be still
like bruh i get that that's how they did
it before
is this is not before we're in after now
so
do it the after way uh let's bring up a
couple van life tick tocks here just to
see just
oh damn that's a nice one
yeah feet what no oh this one's pretty
sick i've seen this one
damn so the thing about this
is that's just on the side of a highway
yeah you know yeah so this looks awesome
but it's not camping at all you're
parked on the side of a road yeah and
that's that's what most of like van
camping is
because every campsite in california is
booked up for the next year
so camp is actually impossible you have
to use this app called overlander
which tells you all the spots and every
place you go that don't have parking
rules
so we were in huntington we just parked
on the side of the street in this
neighborhood because there was no
parking rules
sweet and i'm like this is most of what
van camping actually is
yeah it's just like parking on the side
of a road which is still fun but it's
not like this
what people like glorified yeah unless
you go to like oregon and you're like
in the middle of a forest and you're on
government land and you can post out
wherever
then it becomes like that but most like
california fan life stuff is just
on the side of pch yeah cars screaming
by you all night
yeah which is you know why you have to
take the baby to utah
so you can raise it in the middle of a
forest in a van yeah
in utah yeah the ones that trip me out
are the people that buy buses
and then raise four kids in them
that's like anyway let's let this one
run and then i'll
is this the same bus or the same van oh
this is an actual bus this is a school
bus i've seen this one
that's [ __ ] sick it is
yeah it's cool it's definitely cool so
you know i wanted to get into it
so i rented a winnebago mm-hmm
um and that's like i rented their like
sprinter van so it's not a full-on rv
winnebagos traditionally are like
gigantic rvs yeah
which i think you need a special license
for you do yeah
it's like who drives those things around
you know you know um
dare i say what i know a guy drives a
big ass
rv like basically a tour bus to the
track
it's really weird and what just posts up
there all day
yeah i mean once you're there
it's [ __ ] sick because it's like a
mobile you just have a
home wait i could sell my house
get a rv live at the track
yeah yes yes
this podcast is over this podcast is
done
i'm gonna raise my child at the track at
the track we're gonna live off of hot
dogs
and fried zucchini grows up with
tinnitus yeah he spends his whole
infant years
[Laughter]
yeah bro um so yeah i wanted to get into
the van life so i
rented this van for the weekend on
outdoorsy you can like rent other
people's vans
yeah this is how these people make money
it's pretty crazy it's like a whole side
business for the owners of this van now
mm-hmm i bought this winnebago it's like
150k or something like that and they
rents it out
pretty much every weekend to other
people and it just pays for itself in
like a couple years and they have like a
free town they can use
that's awesome so they bought a second
one and that's the one i rented
and uh i gotta say it was [ __ ]
awesome how many people [ __ ] those
things do you think
i don't know i didn't think about that
but sorry yeah
we slept on those beds so
i just imagine that's there was a crusty
part of one of them
porn has never been made easier yeah oh
no we'll just get a van on
outdoorsy where this stupid app is
parking spaces
oh jesus man that's [ __ ] up sucking
toes
i'm gonna suck some toes for today's
video
sorry so where'd you get you slept in
huntington well we
we actually never slept enough
well we rented it and we were like we're
gonna go up to pismo beach cause i got a
spot on that like
beach that you can camp on yeah yeah and
uh
we were like should we just go down to
san diego instead
it'd be cool to hang out with sam and
nat [ __ ] it so we just drove down to san
diego
i parked it outside of their apartment
and then with the intention of sleeping
in it and then i slept
i fell asleep on the couch and then i
woke up at 5 00 a.m
and went to the van slept in it from
five to eight so okay
i spent a good three hours in there
sleeping so yeah it was just what you're
saying is
i'm gonna have a baby now i'm raising
and raising yeah in a van yep
that's that's awesome it was pretty sick
and the next day we just
parked it outside of our house and the
next day we went down to newport and
spent the day there
yeah and like napped in it and then i
mean it is cool to have like a little
you know mobile retreat oh it's [ __ ]
awesome
yeah it's so sick all right next time i
rented i'm gonna do it for real we're
gonna go to big sur
joshua tree and just like hang there for
three days
what i wanted like during the pandemic
i was this close to
because i was looking at different cars
and basically i was
about to invest in like a like a you
know
with a four-wheeler car that can like
off-road then i wanted to do like the
roof tent
and like do one of those like crazy
kitted-out
cars it's like kind of like van life but
not really because like
it's like you have like a truck bed and
you sleep in a sleeping bag it's way
more rugged
but you can it's more about the
performance of the car because you know
i'm a [ __ ] loser
i was just thinking it'd be sick to have
that and just you know drive off road in
crazy places and like
drive up mountains and just sleep in
like some storm and tent you know
hard mode yep camping it is like weirdly
i don't know romantic yeah something
about that yeah idea
this is just an idea but i think i would
have fun on the driving part yeah when i
got up to the top and like
camping kind of sucks i have to raise
the tent i know that's why rvs are kind
of sick
yeah it's just you don't have to worry
about [ __ ] you have everything shower
oil yeah beers
[Laughter]
ice cold coronas yeah
yeah we should maybe we should build a
winnebago
i mean i want to build one eventually
one day if i have an extra six months
just where i'm not doing [ __ ] yeah i
think it'd be a lot of fun yeah but i
was 20 years [ __ ]
so hard what in 20 years yeah exactly
when i'm retired yeah
there's literally no time that's gonna
happen you know you know who
kind of in that vein uh let's do
tavarish on youtube
super like interesting story as far as
like a creator goes
um he's done all kinds of [ __ ] with cars
he basically
he had like a really popular video and
within the last year you might have seen
it it's like
i bought a 800 pip my ride van off of
craigslist what
yeah uh just looking up on you no way
that's sick
tavares t-a-v-a-r-i-s-h i forget
the name of his channel be careful
why taverish to their-ish did you see
that tick-tock
it's like kid's like dude it's such a
tragedy with having a mark man like i
hope he's gonna make a full recovery
and the kid goes he turns around and he
goes mark
mark my balls in your mouth mark mark
[Laughter]
so he i believe
um he lives in florida and i was
actually gonna
build the next hot laps car with him
okay it didn't work out
just because of distance but he
i think he started in like a small
garage
you know just like a single car garage
and now he's got this warehouse with a
lift
and he has all these crazy projects like
he'll buy
totaled like he bought a totaled lambo
and he restored it
like to perfect and you know that
peterson automobile museum
they they borrowed it from him no way as
an exhibit
that's sick yeah i mean this dude's
awesome oh my god
so um you could let this run with no
with no volume
but he basically just takes on these
like crazy car projects
and he's just kind of like all diy like
he's just like a car nerd that just like
yeah
just does this man it's so cool when
people
like are unbelievably successful at
their passions
yeah out of nowhere yeah yeah his i mean
his story and just like him as a person
is like he's great
yeah so he bought this car on craigslist
and he does
all kinds of [ __ ] and i and and i
i look at him and i think as far as like
cars and stuff go
i think the way he does it is actually
the best way because
he'll find like an aston martin db9
that's like totaled out for some obscure
reason
and it'll be on sale for i don't know 10
grand or something
and it's literally like if you have the
like the luxury of like parking that
somewhere and just figuring it out
you can have like a v12 race car yeah
for uh like
fractions of what you would pay well
dude someone like most of
most actually the vans that i've seen
built on youtube are like
three thousand dollar dodge vans yeah
and then the materials and everything
are another like three grand
yeah so people if you if you have like
if you know what you're doing it takes
like two months but if you don't
takes like six months if you dedicate
yourself for that you can have a full-on
home for six grand
and people then people go to the
mountains and they snowboard forever
or at least forever just for the rest of
their life yeah for the that's it six
grand you can see no more
the rest of your life you also have to
like learn how to hunt and all that
stuff yeah
who cares about that yeah so it's just
like showing the episode that this came
from and
i want to see what like skip to the
middle i forget what happened in this
video it's been a long time since i've
seen it i want to say they ripped a lot
of this stuff
out yeah oh wow because i think that was
a condition
of a lot of the pit my ride cars
was they would just they would take a
lot of those products back out
and like you wouldn't really get to keep
a lot of it
so they would pimp it and then like
de-pimp it yeah basically yeah
like i think it was it was basically
like people who were
selling piece of [ __ ] cars and then the
production would be like hey we'll buy
the car from you and we'll pay and we'll
just like create this story for you to
be on the show gosh yeah
that's really funny yeah huh love this
dude's channel so does he like
re make this car or does he like do
anything to it i want to say he
restores it that's awesome
damn he i mean he just he's got all
kinds of i gotta check this guy out
yeah he kills it on youtube as well
sorry bro you're good man it's that
macaroni sitting in there
yeah that that that food court macaroni
is crazy
it's pretty good and why is it green
oh oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the thing
that you like macaroni that's like how
tired you are you completely forgot yes
yeah
yeah from the space mac space mac is
it's [ __ ] up man it makes you dooky
extra
that's for sure yep
you